або дачі шан вмієте я обожнюю вам
горнова дня я просто хотіла сказати ще
вам на мачуху нас боятися
ми тут просто гості я хочу у нас буде
шанс ми всі через воду ним по вірному
сліду будинку
юджин мустафа сд єдність при que todo
інвалідного скроні пити годину бомбарду wine
волі за
вона лиж з чужої допомоги випускалося
їжею підвалу
у видно снах безтурботними сем випнулися а
а д бомбардування ми ви вирішив ці коти
допомогою астані тільки ночей було б
сонним і
відомому спочив і думати ще можемо
вигнути і ще вже завтра буду момент
вами Юджин тепер живу не міг шинель і
адже виду і школу бали з банани
мовлади гору б ти через церебральний
параліч дівчина бджола сять удома багатієм
багатим дітям
[ __ ] тим людям у всьому us within a так
почистив і від мене зараз tomoya
навчилася вона дуже скажи тис а вона в
Бувай
атр йому в це задував вони на вигляд
домашкою то так приймальному а то циві трохи
адже у тебе нормального жити а
zara дати його нормального жити вони джин
здавалася з тисяч кілометрів тобто
всю Європу за допомогу і якщо стрип
дівчина я колоритно мала по машинах
догляду лаз будинку dish долоні матч іншим у
тим по шеронового пики столу нема біженців
через збентеження джин геть їхніх мереж люди шкіряні
волосну історію кожне дівчисько
пливуть його Тетяна ви там завжди лаша
цифри цифри цифри це диван і завтра
кажуть брехня і про і d росії режим він і
би скін особисто говорити про політику та
забувають про людей я не хочу стати за
допомогу британського автора дівчинка
написала книгу про свої життя
поспішаю і на бійку вали англійську atpl
перикла наймати cool юджин показу їй
своїм батькам по skype геть і дісталася
алеппо дату річчоні
дівчатам річку Лессі знову but is ним і
розум ви на такий хочеш рахунок
міжнародної spilota наріжте видно
було мер у сирі я думаю політикою європе
ванни і гуде і
і кенозеро було домашні завдання вам
труба взято на особливий вид
тому вам піци лузи планети тисячі
відбувається в результаті люди зможе повернутися
сюди своїх думі вам
нібито дівчинки не личило сюжету про не
матч і не one of stage хочу повернути
все до своєї батьківщини
проти ніхто не можете сказати і колодязі
будди та чиї буду в залі